thank you so much and thank you dear
Sydney and wonderful and net sitting out
here with all of you enjoying this
wonderful evening made me think back to
the first time I saw one of these
there's a long time ago within it was on
March the 15th 1944 I was 11 years old
my father was away at war preparing for
d-day
he'd been nominated for directing for a
movie called the more the merrier and I
was planning on going to @y night
doubleheader between the Hollywood stars
and the San Francisco SEALs down at
Gilmore field over there on Beverly and
my mother told me that instead we were
going to Grauman's Chinese and that my
father won this award I was going to
accept it I remember I putting on an
itchy suit and going to the Chinese with
my mother and my grandmother and my
mother saying that how gracious the
Stars sitting around us were Jean Arthur
Jennifer Jones Ingrid Bergman when the
others picture would win for art
direction or sound and they would
applaud it was so nice and then a fine
director of the day Marc sandwich came
on the stage to present the award for
Best Director and I was ready but you
should understand this I knew the
batting averages of every player in the
Hollywood stars lineup but I had never
heard of Casablanca
Marx and Rich read the names open the
envelope and he said Michael Curtiz
Casablanca and unlike the gracious
ladies sitting around me my mother said
that I had a deep and rather resonant
voice for a boy my age I said we was
robbed but you see I mean I didn't grow
up to come here I want it to be a sports
writer my heroes were Grantland rice and
red Smith and maybe it was partly a
little thing of self-preservation that I
didn't want to devote my life to
becoming the second best film director
and my family but it you know I had this
legacy my grandmother Georgia would
Thorpe was the great actress of the age
in San Francisco she played Ophelia
to Edwin booths Hamlet and her daughter
Georgie Cooper married Lander Stevens
they were both actor and actress matinee
idols in San Francisco and Landers was a
director and when the movies ruined the
theater they moved to Hollywood the next
time you see swing time that handsome
gray-haired man who plays the father of
the girl that Fred Astaire stands up at
her wedding
that's Lander Stephens and my other
grandmother Alice Howell she came here
and starred in the first six films that
Charlie Chaplin made and went on to make
a hundred more and my mother she was a
Mack Sennett bathing beauty until she
retired to raise me so it sort of in our
blood and my daughter Caroline is here
she's a documentary filmmaker my son
Michael is a writer producer director
he's in Washington tonight producing the
Kennedy Center Honors probably making me
irrelevant
and so they are fifth-generation and
show business which makes listen be
especially proud of our son David with
his doctoral degree from Harvard and his
company called Symphony learning he is
teaching children to learn and at long
last he is proven that as Stevens can
make a living in the real world
I went I went back to the Oscars years
later this time with my father and I sat
next to him the night he won for a place
in the Sun and riding home that night he
was driving the car was different in
those days
and the the Oscar was on the seat
between us and I was pretty excited of
it and I think he thought I was a little
too excited he leaned over smiled and he
said something that shaped my life he
said we'll have a better idea what kind
of a film this is in about 25 years he
was talking about the test of time and
it was the test of time that was the
underlying idea and the ethic of the
American Film Institute and later the
Kennedy Center Honors
so I thank dad for that and for opening
the door for me to a creative life that
has been so rich and and gifted me with
so many wonderful friends in our
profession and the test of time I've
seen a couple of pictures this fall that
I I'm confident will stand the test of
time and I think it is so important that
there are filmmakers among us who will
swim into the currents who will
challenge the industrial
industrialization of moviemaking to make
films that are filled with passion and
glory and pity and sacrifice and reached
to the depths of our humanity and so
thinking of that I thank the Academy I
thank the Board of Governors and this
means a great deal to me because of our
shared values about the importance and
the value of film
so tonight I say here's the great films
of the future and I should add tonight I
wasn't robbed thanks so much